hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about the plateau the doldrums
when we feel we're not making progress
in a language and you know i am i guess
considered a polyglot because i speak a
number of languages
i have preferred the term linguist but
polyglot seems increasingly accepted
although many english speakers don't
know the term
uh
but the idea some people may have the
idea that polyglots
just kind of breeze through learning new
languages that is not the case i think
our
path through acquiring languages is not
unlike that of other people
we have that initial period you know
i've spoken about this upside down
hockey stick that initial period the
blade of the hockey stick where we make
rapid
progress we acquire new words we get a
sense you know what was just total noise
all of a sudden becomes comprehensible
to some degree and then we hit this
stage where we've gone through like in
my case would be the many stories on
link i've gone through this basic
material i've acquired some words i can
say a few things but now
i have to acquire so many words in order
to reach genuine fluency or at least to
be able to understand movies and to be
able to have you know random
conversations on many subjects and that
actually is a long long road
and so
once we hit that and we you know we some
people simply stay in the learner
material and never progress beyond that
but other people want to push themselves
into this more difficult material and as
they do so they start to realize that
whereas in the initial period
you know high frequency high frequency
words
are high frequency so they appear more
often
but then because frequency the frequency
with which verbs or words verbs words
appear in any text drops off very very
quickly so pretty soon we have to
acquire lots of relatively low frequency
words and therefore
it takes a long long time to move from
it might be like a2 to b2 that's a long
long road and very often we have the
feeling that we're not getting anywhere
and uh some people refer to this as the
plateau i would also call it the
doldrums i remember from elementary
school we were taught about the trade
winds east west
west east trade winds and in between
along the equator was an area where
often there would be no winds and so in
days of
sailing ships of course that means that
without wind the ships aren't moving and
so you get into this stage in language
learning where you feel you're not
moving and i'm kind of in that stage
right now
with my arabic persian and turkish
i've done the many stories in the three
languages i have a sense now of how
those languages work i have some
vocabulary forget it relearn it forget
it relearn it but i have a bit of a
sense of the language i'm pushing myself
now to more difficult content uh in the
case of arabic i go to franz mankat and
al jazeera to their podcast which i then
have automatically transcribed
uh
similarly with farsi i go to fardo and i
do the same
turkish we seem to have a lot of good
content in our library at link so i i
simply look to see what's there and
study what's there
but it's difficult it is difficult
especially in arabic it's the most
difficult because it's a totally
different language system and it's a
different writing system
persian is indo-european language
turkish is at least written in the latin
alphabet so those two are easier than
arabic
so
you know what do i do
at times i get discouraged i'm not
getting anywhere it seems almost as
difficult now as it was before
even though on my lesson page it i can
see
that you know there are fewer blue words
there are more yellow words more white
words so i think the first thing that i
have to do
as i'm in the plateau is i just have to
stay the course i have to remember that
when i was learning czech or russian for
example or greek there was a long period
when i was listening to
you know
podcasts that i didn't really understand
and i kept listening to them and it
seemed like i would never get to where i
could just enjoyably listen to a podcast
and understand it and yet in the end i
got there so the first thing is that and
i as someone who has learned quite a few
languages to varying levels
i'm confident that i will eventually get
to a stage where i can understand movies
i can listen to podcasts i can read
newspapers and i can speak with mistakes
so the first thing is to stay the course
the second thing is to
you know have certain sort of habits
that you automatically do that you have
to do so that's why i force myself i'm
not always able to do it but i've tried
to force myself to create a hundred
links a day in each language
it's just a mechanical thing i have to
do it even if sometimes i cheat
and i just go from blue word to blue to
blue word without reading the whole text
planning to go back and read it later on
just so that i maintain that habit
similarly i have a habit of looking to
see what's new in the turkish library
you know i go to our lesson feed in
turkish see what's there
pick something new and go through it uh
similarly i like to grab a podcast from
al jazeera or franz madquez
and listen to it don't understand it
very well but it's it's just one of
these things it's like something new i
think we like things that are new i find
it more enticing to listen to a new
podcast that i understand him perfectly
rather than to go i have uh the ass
email that i have transcribed but it's
it's uninteresting it's stuff that was
written long ago it's not it's not
interesting so i have this habit i go to
the podcast
but so then so stay the course
uh create some habits remind yourself
why you're learning so
i was feeling a bit discouraged should i
give up give up on turkish and persian
focus on arabic because arabic is more
difficult and then i was in a pharmacy
the other day and there's this iranian
lady and so we say a few things in
persian i realize how much my persian
you know it's not as good as it was
uh so that gets me going back to my
persian and then she said she was
interested in learning turkish and of
course and then i'm reminded of the the
relationship between these languages and
and my wife is watching this uh turkish
movie on netflix about the seljuk turks
in anatolia fighting the crusaders and
and then i'm reminded that the
the seljuk empire included modern day
iran
and um
arab-speaking areas and anatolia and so
there's this tremendous historical
connection
and this lady wants she's iranian she
wants to learn turkish and so i'm
reminded why i'm doing it i'm doing it
to discover
something about these languages so
mastery of these is very elusive far
away but it is
interesting to me to be discovering
these so i'm interested in what i'm
trying to discover
um that's my goal i know it's worthwhile
i have certain habits that i've created
and i'm staying the course so with that
i have to plow through i'm in the
doldrums the wind isn't blowing i don't
feel i'm getting anywhere but i have to
stay with it i can also do some things
to make it better so for example
i had a podcast uh that was out about
politics by the way i'm trying to figure
out where the camera is and make sure my
eye stays on the camera rather than the
center of my iphone it's a little
difficult but
um so i i downloaded this podcast from
franz fatka there was a discussion about
politics in lebanon with a lebanese
politician
and uh i got the automatic transcript
and it's very inaccurate so it's
difficult to make sense of it as i try
to read through
uh although i save words
that's why i said well you know what i
should get a newspaper article on this
so i
google
newspapers in lebanon up comes a
wikipedia page and has a list of
newspapers in lebanon in arabic french
and armenian so i choose the arabic list
and there's a newspaper called el shark
uh the east
and there's an article
about the
political situation in lebanon so i
import that article into link so now i'm
going through some of the same material
but now it's written in a way that makes
sense because this is an
actual newspaper article
now i feel i have a better chance to
make sense of this automatically
transcribed podcast and to listen to the
podcast so i think these are the kinds
of things that we can do
uh i think in the new year at link we're
going to make the library much better
it's going to be easier to find stuff
hopefully we can get people who
have good content to sell it across link
i would happily pay i'm paying 10 an
hour to have this stuff automatically
transcribed i went to
upwork which is an outsourcing website
to see if i could find someone who would
transcribe person in arabic
and i said i want your cost or your
price per audio hour and they come back
and they say i'll charge 10 an hour that
doesn't tell me how much they would
charge to do a whole audio
hour of a podcast one person said it's a
hundred dollars u.s an hour i'm
certainly not going to pay that
so
the other way is we have for example um
lingualism who's gonna hopefully we can
arrange with him and others i spoke to
someone who has turkish material as well
where they can sell their content across
link i would happily spend ten twenty
dollars to get audio and text access to
good content
for learning these languages so these
are some of the things that we can do
you know to help us along
at any rate
when we're in the doldrums when we're at
that plateau you have to convince
yourself that what you're doing is worth
it
you got to be sure you know why you're
doing it you've got to have certain
habits that you essentially do every day
whether it be creating links or
listening to podcasts looking for what's
new in the library or the lesson feed
and link
and and remember that it is very
worthwhile just the other day i was
looking at a picture from an old timer's
hockey tournament that i was at in 2006
and i saw all of our pictures there and
i said gee that's 13 years ago
um
and i think you know today i am more
excited
about
learning about new cultures new
languages
uh it it gives me
so much reward which i didn't have back
then when i hadn't yet really started my
you know
intense study of languages so it does
give you a lot and and your goal can be
mastery what you like doing might be you
might enjoy going to class you might
enjoy doing anki decks you might enjoy
whatever but do things that you enjoy
doing
stay the course and you will eventually
get through the plateau thank you for
listening bye for now